[Musik]
immer mehr Patientinnen und Patienten zu
wenig Personal
sich Situationen
die Notfallstationen in der Schweiz sind
überlastet aber es tut ihm
wahrscheinlich schwer weil so
geschwollen ist
für die Patienten bleibt häufig zu wenig
Zeit die Arbeitsbelastung
was läuft schief auf den
Notfallstationen in der Schweiz
[Musik]
wir ein Reporter-Team des Schweizer
Fernsehens begleiten eine Spätschicht
auf dem kispinotfall in St Gallen
wir wollen wissen unter welchen
Umständen wird hier eigentlich
gearbeitet
[Musik]
Pflegefachfrau
seit drei Jahren arbeitet sie auf der
Notfallstation des Kinderspital St
Gallen
Gina Busch nimmt uns mit auf die Station
es ist Freitagabend Schichtbeginn
super okay
bereits seit einer halben Stunde im
Dienst ist Oberärztin sind ja überall
sie ist die Leiterin dieser
notfallschicht du bist der Julian
passiert
[Musik]
das Kinderärzte Eltern an den
notfallverweisen das werden wir an
diesem Abend oft hören
genau da muss man ja super machst du da
genau ja und wenn du willst kannst du
auch sauber
Luft das ist Lachgas um die Kinder zu
beruhigen es ist nicht so toll also ich
denke nicht dass die Sehnen oder so
kaputt sind und von Knochen her würde
ich auch kein trink gemacht nein also
wir machen schon drauf das muss so eine
Stunde wirken
[Musik]
eine Schnittwunde am Knie ist das jetzt
tatsächlich ein Notfall oder eher eine
Bagatelle
sind wir sehr häufig also mehrmals pro
Tag
also ja ist nicht so eine tiefe Wunde
oder so da kann man es schnell nah auf
der Notfall ja warum schickt der
Kinderarzt einen banalen Fall in den
Notfall die Antwort auf diese Frage
werden wir später erhalten
was passiert
also dass mir der Name küssend
ung zur Pflegefachfrau gewusst habe sie
will einmal auf dem Notfall arbeiten
[Musik]
was ist cool und wo beginnt Überlastung
das wollen wir an diesem Abend
herausfinden
an die Wunde von Julia wie gewünscht
hatte Bub zu Entspannung Lachgas
gekriegt
[Musik]
super verstehst Du schauen wie es
aussieht
Julian wird das Spital bald verlassen
können
ist seit 15 Jahren in der Notfallmedizin
tätig lange Zeit arbeitete sie in
Schweden seit drei Jahren ist sie am St
Gallen egal wo auf dem kindernotfall sei
vor allem eines wichtig immer den Eltern
und Familie gut zu Hause weil wir wissen
die Kinder nur ganz kurz 15 Minuten die
Familie und Eltern kennen ja ihre Kinder
am besten einfach zu Hause und
Bauchgefühl und ja
ebenfalls eingeteilt ist der Leiter der
Station ivoigloffstein er macht einen
Zusatzdienst um das Personal zu
entlasten
auch auf ivoigloffstein wartet ein
Patient bei dem genäht werden muss
so gut dass es gar nicht mehr weh tut
nun so
super aufgerissen
Entschuldigung
wunderbar
auch Patient mehr sah mit seiner
lippenverletzung wurde vom Hausarzt ans
Spital überwiesen
[Musik]
vor 20 Jahren
Hausarztpraxis gemacht worden
Haus und Kinderarztpraxen seien für
diese sogenannt kleine Traumatologie
nicht mehr ausgerüstet sagt die
klofstein und das habe einen Grund
Politik gewollt und vom Sparen
das Tun selbst sind sowieso keinem
gebraucht hinten automatische Spital
das sei eine der Gründe warum viel mehr
Patienten und Patienten bei Ihnen auf
dem Notfall landeten sagt die klopfstein
dass die meisten unnötig kämen will er
nicht bestätigen
Pferde
es ist später Nachmittag noch sei die
Anzahl der Patienten überschaubar sagt
uns Genia Bush Gewichte Timo okay mein
Name ist Busch
was passiert ist gut super
Patient timo ist 13 Jahre alt und kommt
aus Appenzell
Notfall St Gallen
[Musik]
super okay
sie wird recht behalten timo hat keine
Blinddarmentzündung weil Platz und
Personal knapp sind auf der
Notfallstation
werden alle Fälle reagiert
das heißt dringendes hat Priorität das
jonglierende Zeit und Ressourcen ein
ständiges Thema hier
wie lange dauert bis sie nach Hause
können wenn jetzt nicht dauernd andere
Kinder kommen die festkrank sind dann
vielleicht eine Stunde das okay gut
die Patientenzahlen auf dem kiesby
Notfall in St Gallen haben sich in den
letzten zehn Jahren verdoppelt
das Einzugsgebiet des Spitals ist groß
Babys und Kinder bis 16 Jahre aus den
Kanton Thurgau St Gallen und den beiden
Appenzell kommen hierher die
patientenzunahme der letzten Jahre hat
Kosten folgen sie Behandlung auf dem
Notfall kostet im Schnitt doppelt so
viel wie beim Haus oder Kinderarzt
hat eine neue Patientin die dreijährige
Ayla aus Niederuzwil
nach Hause gekommen das erste ist mir
aufgefallen ist die Mutter des Mädchens
erzählt uns warum Sie direkt auf der
Notfall gekommen ist anstatt zuerst zum
Kinderarzt zu gehen
ich habe drei Kinder also für gar kein
Kind bekomme ich Termine bin froh dass
du überhaupt also sie ist die älteste
ich bin froh dass überhaupt meine
nächsten zwei Wochen aufgenommen hat und
der hat auch nur aufgenommen weil es
eben neugeborene sind sonst hat er mir
gesagt er würde es nicht nehmen es ist
voll Engpass gut
es wird sich herausstellen dass das
Mädchen Ayla Scharlach hat eine Diagnose
die nicht auf dem Notfall hätte gemacht
werden müssen doch solche Fälle von
Eltern deren einzige Anlaufstelle der
Notfall sei hätten sich gehäuft sagt uns
Ivo Egloffstein
Regionen und für alle Autos Kategorie
wirklich gut
tragfähig heißt
und Kinder
die hohe notfallzahlen lassen sich also
erklären mit weniger Haus und
Kinderärzten überlasteten Kinderärzten
und Praxen die nicht mehr ausgerüstet
sind um die sogenannte Traumatologie zu
übernehmen
was nirgends Platz findet landet auf dem
Notfall
doch hier trifft mehr Arbeit auf zu
wenig Personal
die denkbar schlechteste Kombination
es ist der erste dringliche Fall für
Pflegefachfrau Busch an diesem Abend mit
dabei
Assistenzärztin Janine hedmayer.de
alles ganz doof junge
zum ersten Mal haben wir den Eindruck
Gina Busch sei angespannt
[Musik]
das ist doch super
prüfen ob das Mädchen genügend
Sauerstoff kriegt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja genau
Ilona sei ein Frühgeborenes Kind gewesen
erzählen uns die Eltern darum sei sie
die Sauerstoffmaske geworden okay
[Musik]
Situationen
im Verlaufe des Abends immer schlechter
gehen
mitkommen es ist mittlerweile kurz nach
19 Uhr und die Anzahl Patienten hat
zugenommen
das sei üblich sagt uns so bereits den
Gübeli
auf der Nordbahn danke
[Musik]
am Anfang aber jetzt im Moment mal keine
brechen Veränderungen
[Musik]
muss eine Stunde wirken dürfen sie noch
mal mit den Gang warten dann hole ich
noch eine fliegen würde mit der Schädel
draufkleben ja
auch die Verletzung von Jan ist ein
einfacher Fall die Kinderärztin hat die
Mutter ans Notfall Spital verwiesen
wir wollen von der Oberärztin wissen wie
sehr sie bei der Arbeit unter Druck
steht
sie unterschiedlich von Dienst natürlich
aber die Arbeitsbelastung ist meistens
sehr hoch bei uns würde ich sagen und
wir haben ja ein Personalmangel zu
wenige Pflege zu wenige Ärzte das ist
leider überall so in der ganzen Schweiz
auf dem Kisbee Notfall in St Gallen sind
derzeit nicht alle Stellen besetzt im
April sollte das Team wieder komplett
sein
mittlerweile ist es 7:30 Uhr und
sämtliche notfallbetten sind besetzt
magst wollt ihr Nackenschmerzen ins neue
nehmen
[Musik]
Sie die Rettung ins 1 super so machen
wir es gut
genug
wir sind zurück bei Ilona der Mädchen
mit den Atemproblemen
[Musik]
relativ hochfährt
jetzt relativ streng mit Stufen
wenn macht macht
sie sehr lecker
[Musik]
ungefähr zwei bis drei Minuten bis sie
fertig bin am besten nehmen Sie sich so
auf der Schoß
das zweijährige Mädchen wird an diesem
Abend nicht nach Hause gehen können
[Musik]
super sehr gut sein Zustand wird sich
verschlechtern das mit dem Inhalieren
20 Minuten insgesamt die Eltern werden
uns später bitten nicht mehr zu filmen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und dann schauen wir einmal die Lunge an
Pflegefachfrau und Assistenzärztin
arbeiten Hand in Hand ihr Archie denken
gebe es auf dem Notfall nicht sagen die
beiden
uns wird hier klar wie hoch der Druck
und wie anspruchsvoll die Arbeit ist
[Musik]
100% oder mit 90%
kein schaffen
[Musik]
Problem dass sie das Kind haben wo
aktuelles dokumentiert jetzt nur sogar
schnell schnell
Stationsleiter Ivo Egloffstein hat die
Unterlippe des vierjährigen mirsa genäht
[Musik]
und seine Mutter sind aus dem Spital
entlassen
[Musik]
vom Stationsleiter wollen wir wissen ob
in dieser Drucksituation die Sicherheit
auf dem Notfall jederzeit gewährleistet
ist
eigentlich so ist es schwierig ein
Notfall wiederbetriebe da ist Sicherheit
nicht nur für alle Patienten
dass ich weiß jederzeit weiß wo wenn wir
ganz Wellen Patienten oder zum Glück gut
und ganz mit auf Englisch Patientin wo
wir sind das ist nicht so wie Grund
liegt dass einfach Mitarbeiter alles und
noch viel mehr drüber gehen
es ist kurz nach 20 Uhr
Pflegefachfrau Busch nimmt uns mit in
die Personalküche
zieht da in der Küche
wir wollen vom Team wissen wie sie
abschalten können vom Stress der Arbeit
ich brauche vor allem persönlich die
räumliche Distanz das ist mir ganz
wichtig dass ich einfach weit genug weg
bin vom Notfall vor allem ablenke und
Gedanken
mit dem Umgang
jedem einzelnen egal ob es jetzt
Ruhefläche oder
privatisch dadurch dass wir so
eingeschweißt sind und so ein cooles
Team haben ich glaube das hat die
Situation
dann auch erträglicher gemacht diesen
letzten Monaten und Jahren
heute hat es für zehn Minuten Pause
gereicht das schafften sie etwa an jedem
dritten Tag erzählen sie uns
[Musik]
nebenan bei Oberärztin Gübeli sieht ein
bisschen anders aus
[Musik]
das Gott ich habe schon hier gegessen
ja
also ich muss den Überblick behalten ist
ein paar Kinder jetzt da und Sie schauen
einfach dass das vorwärts
da kann man als Konto und
Pflegefachfrau Busch hat bereits einen
nächsten Fall die einjährige Valentina
[Musik]
der Hund
valentina ist vom Bett gefallen
nicht aber ja letzte Handgriffe von
Ärztin Gübeli und Pflegefachfrau Anna
Klee beim fünfjährigen louan
[Musik]
werden
sich beim Trampolinspringen die Bänder
verletzt
die Schicht sei heute normal gewesen
nicht besonders anstrengend sagt uns das
Notfall-Team aber normal heißt eben
mittlerweile zu viel
Pflegefachfrau Busch sagt sie bräuchte
Entlastung
die Arbeit auf mehr Personal verteilen
und so die einzelnen entlasten das wäre
eine Lösung
doch Stationsleiter igloffstein sagt
mehr Personal lasse sich derzeit gar
nicht rekrutieren
ja
[Musik]
Gesundheitsökonomen und Politiker werden
es ist kurz vor 22 Uhr Oberärztin Gübeli
hat bei louan fertig gegipst
[Musik]
viel Verantwortung und immer mehr Druck
der Alltag der oberärztin
danke danke
es hat mir eben interessiert wir sind
Mensch funktioniert mit Biologie wie
kann wie so kann man so gut hören also
wie sind die Prozesse im Körper das muss
wie man interessiert aber auch mit
Menschen zu arbeiten und so finde
spannend
danke
[Musik]
nach drei Stunden kann luan Heim mit
seinem Gips in fünf Wochen kommt er zum
Röntgen wieder
auf der Station ist Schichtwechsel
die meisten Fälle an diesem Abend waren
nicht dringlich das heißt keine Fälle
für eine Notfallstation
doch egal wie groß der Druck ist
abgewiesen wird hier niemand
eine Notfallstation schließt nie
[Musik]